[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et vos ailes de poulet c'est ce dimanche
que les gosses de Philadelphie et les
cheese de Kenza esthétique on
s'affronter à l'occasion du 50/7
Superbowl il y a plus de 100 millions
d'Américains qui devraient regarder le
match en fin de semaine des retombées
économiques faramineuses on va en parler
avec Franck font aussi les directeurs de
l'Observatoire international en
management du sport doyen de la Faculté
des sciences de l'administration de
l'Université Laval bonsoir Monsieur
ponce
bonsoir Adrian alors le superbow c'est
encore une fois la fête du football
est-ce que c'est encore l'événement avec
les retombées économiques les plus
importantes pour le sport américain
sur une journée c'est effectivement
l'événement avec les plus grosses
retombées on profitable vous en discuter
il est très très profitable bien entendu
mais est-ce que c'est le plus profitable
c'est un débat en tout cas c'est
l'événement majeur effectivement aux
États-Unis sur une journée sur des
durées plus longues on en a d'autres à
travers le monde aux États-Unis c'est
lui qui a la palme pour plein de raisons
les retombées économiques les revenus
l'exposition la visibilité les
publicités on en passe bon alors
retomber économique là on va regarder
d'abord pour la région de Phoenix où on
accueille ce 57e super bon on va
regarder le prix des billets ensemble on
a préparé un tableau franchement ça
donne une petite idée là ça prend des
moyens pour y assister on a le prix le
plus bas c'est autour de 5000 dollars le
prix moyen plus de 7000 dollars et le
prix le plus élevé on est à presque
30000 dollars qu'est-ce qui explique que
c'est si cher
ça ça donne le tournis il y a plusieurs
facteurs qui expliquent ça d'abord il y
a une accessibilité oubliée qui
relativement limité bon on comprend que
c'est un match sur une journée la
répartition des billets est particulière
aussi les les deux équipes se partagent
17% des billets donc pour leur femme
pour qu'on ait des gens qui vont nous
supporter mais la NFL garde à peu près
25 % pour ses opérations internes plutôt
de la vente et les autres équipes les
autres 29 équipes se partagent à peu
près 1% chacune de la mise en marché
donc mise en marché qui limite le nombre
et l'accessibilité à l'événement qui
explique le prix et si on ajoute à ça le
côté visibilité de l'événement où tout
le monde veut être vu ça explique les
prix et l'inflation des prix qu'on a
année après année ça date plutôt des
années 2000 2010 on a commencé à avoir
une explosion des prix en 1970 80 90 ça
serait à peu près 100 dollars actuels
donc on a évolué beaucoup et clairement
donc le soupe est beau qui se tient à
Phoenix en Arizona cette année Phénix
qui a déjà accueilli le super ball
d'ailleurs à deux reprises 2008 2015
est-ce qu'on a une idée retombées
économique que ça peut représenter pour
la ville un événement comme celui-là
oui on a beaucoup d'idées il faut se
méfier toujours des retombées
économiques calculées selon la source on
parle généralement de retombe économique
aux alentours de 400 millions à peu près
pour les les prévisions optimistes j'ai
même vu des précisions très optimistes
pour la région de Phoenix aux alentours
de 700 ou 800 millions la réalité sans
doute beaucoup plus proche de quelque
chose autour de ça 150 millions oui il y
a des retombées énormes sur le marché de
l'emploi sur les taxes mais en même
temps on calcule tous qui est dépensé
alors qu'il y aurait quand même eu de
l'activité dans la région de Phoenix à
ce moment-là on a des coûts qui sont pas
quand on tient rarement en compte donc
c'est des tomber très importantes mais
encore une fois apprendre avec un
petit grain de sel selon l'origine de
qui fait l'évaluation économique bon et
là quand on regarde le superbow monsieur
ponce il y a deux équipes de
téléspectateurs d'un côté ceux qui
regardent le sport de l'autre côté ceux
qui regardent les publicités si on veut
Fox qui diffuse la partie le ça coûte
cher encore une fois cette année pour
annoncer des publicités au Super Bowl
c'est énorme on parle de 7 millions
cette année on a une augmentation
graduelle on était à peu près 6.5
millions l'année dernière on parle d'à
peu près 60 à 70 publicités donc c'est
500 millions de revenus juste pour les
publicités pendant le match donc c'est
énorme et ce qui est intéressant c'est
que vous l'avez dit les spectateurs sont
très variés ou les téléspectateurs les
gens qui assistent au Super Bowl le
regard pour différentes raisons on a les
gens qui veulent voir le match
principalement mais on a quand même à
peu près 15 à 20% des gens qui regardent
le Superbowl pour les publicités et où
pour le spectacle de la mi-temps ce qui
est qui n'arrive jamais surtout pour les
publicités vous n'avez aucun événement à
l'heure actuelle puis on est tous
téléspectateurs dans lequel on va
vouloir avoir la publicité or c'est ce
qui just les gens veulent voir ces
publicités là on les recherche et c'est
unique dans l'année et ça explique le
prix et les retombées potentiels pour
les commentaires et même le spectacle à
mutant là vous l'évoquez monsieur ponce
c'est 15 minutes oui c'est à très grand
déploiement et ça doit coûter cher à
organiser mais est-ce que c'est rentable
en bout de ligne pour un si grand
événement qui dure jusqu'à 15 minutes
c'est rentable en termes d'image
d'associations d'ailleurs on a un
changement cette année qui est notable
pour les gens qui suivent le spectacle
Pepsi qui était le partenaire historique
et on a beaucoup de d'artistes connus
qui sont passés sous la bannière de
Pepsi pendant le Super Bowl et remplacé
par Apple music donc un changement un
petit peu de tendance pour un prix
d'aviron 50 millions de dollars en
question beaucoup sur la valeur
effectivement de la visibilité mais elle
existe est-ce que c'est un bon
investissement le temps dira mais c'est
un investissement qui est justifiable en
tout cas qui qui a un certain rationnel
et le spectacle est très suivi il y a
des gens qui ne se branchent au Super
Bowl que pour voir le spectacle à la
différence des publicités qui sont
étalées donc c'est c'est un
investissement intéressant notre manière
de se présenter et de de présenter un
positionnement surtout pour Apple Music
qui est bien entendu relié au contenu
puisqu'on parle de spectacle musical
bien sûr ça m'amène à ma toute dernière
question monsieur ponce on va se laisser
là-dessus est-ce que le superbow c'est
d'abord une fête du football aussi
davantage une machine à profit est-ce
qu'il y a plus de marketing de sport
il y a énormément de marketing mais n'a
pas plus je pense que c'est un événement
qui sans doute le mieux et en utilisant
admissible marketé ou mise en marché
dans le monde du sport c'est un exemple
sur une journée c'est la fête du
marketing mais c'est la fête du sport
c'est la fête des amoureux de football
donc c'est un bon mariage je pense c'est
la tempête parfaite ou le mariage
parfait puis on va tous être devant nos
écrans en tout cas un grand nombre pour
différentes raisons et on va suivre ça
avec plaisir je te souhaite donc une
bonne soirée dimanche merci beaucoup
d'avoir été ce soir
merci beaucoup au revoir pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez-vous sur la
chaîne ici RDI